[Music]
i have like you
heard the tall tales told about the
marsh girl
an abandoned child
i had a family once
they called me kyle
[Music]
a little girl surviving in the marsh on
her own
reviled
and shunned
hello miss kyle i hear y'all by muscles
[Music]
sometimes i feel so invisible
[Music]
i wonder if i'm here at all
you are
[Music]
i think you're gorgeous
i want to get to know you better
[Music]
there's no fingerprints on the railing
great stuff
no fingerprints
being isolated was one thing
being hunted
quite another you didn't see
me here a marsh girl she killed him i
know you have a world of reasons to hate
these people i never hated them they
hated me they harassed me
you want me to pick from my life
i won't they're not deciding anything
about me
in spite of everything trying to stomp
it out
life persists
way out yonder where the crawdads sing
the marsh knows one thing above all else
[Music]
every creature does what it must to
survive
[Music]
[Music]
you